Hey
Youtubers it's Charlie!
Surprise surprise, there's new Star Wars footage
mostly focusing on Rey's characters so let's
break it down.
I also wanted to do another giveaway for movie
tickets all you have to do to enter is be
a subscriber and leave a comment on this video
It's a gift certificate for the value of two
IMAX tickets for the force awakens which I
think I think it amounts to about $50 so anyway,
let's get going.
we start out with the Millennium falcon on
what looks like the really green planet were
this battle is taking place later I think
that's called Takodana the only reason we
know that though is because that name shows
up as a planet for a data entry for one of
the characters that showed up in other promotional
material here for this ME8 D9 droid it refers
to it is and meet you know just like we say
C-3 PO is three PO attaches and me to the
on allied scoundrels of Takodana so they're
saying on allied they're talking about not
allied with resistance or with the first-order
kind of like clouds city Lando Calrissian
in the original trilogy so this which actually
seems like it might be Maz Kanata's Castle
is probably on this planet there's also rumors
that she's part of that pirate factions of
this action might be where they find Anakin
Skywalker's lightsaber the really important
dialogue she has though is I have lived long
enough to see the same eyes in different people
I see your eyes I know your eyes that this
just a reference to them being the children
of characters from the original trilogy I
don't ever everyone's wondering like who is
the daughter and son of who there is a rumor
that Finn his Lando Calrissian son but that's
based on the description of this Amazon marketing
so I'm I'm looking at that is rather dubious
I'm more and he totally on board with Rey
being the daughter of one of the original
trilogy characters that is not blue and I
do think that she's related one of the antagonist
just this the be very opaque about it but
I don't know about this Finn Lando Calrissian
think that just feels like a version of the
jokes that people use to make about layout
like how she used to be the only woman in
the galaxy I think is an attempt to the new
movies to try to do more accurate Portrayal
of the the citizens of the Galaxy like it
would be vastly diverse vastly different numbers
of species Rey sees genders that even be a
crazy diverse population of droids the thing
is a huge leap to assume that just because
Finn bears some resemblance to Lando Calrissian
that he's his son madly though there will
be children of original trilogy characters
in this movie though but I think this whole
TV spot is more focusing on Rey's character
so I think that line prefers mostly to Rey
and here we see Han Solo on the ice planet
which is not hospitable he evoking a lot of
Empire strikes back imagery this ice planet
is where the first order basis supposed to
be an audible wondering if the planet itself
might be hiding the star killer base this
scene here with Finn and Poulos like it that
a rebel base but it but it also looks like
it's on the same planet is to conduct but
it makes sense of the resistance would try
to bargain with pirates to get the supplies
they needed ships weapons anything they might
want you can kinda see how this invokes episode
four imagery work Werther getting ready to
go on the final assault on the first death
Star see Han Solo taking his money and running
this is the Imperial transports flying overhead
here's Rey getting ready to get into a fight
with her staff project to can can't wait to
see if I with the staff and a lot of people
want this to be like a forced piker something
II don't think that she's going to have a
light saber right away if she's gonna be force
sensitive I think she's only going to figure
it out later in the movie that's what I think
a lot of that math Cannata dialogue from the
previous trailers about the forces calling
to you let it in I think she's talking to
both Finn and Rey this huge structure here
looks like the starkiller bases just evoking
a lot of death star imagery Kylo Ren defecting
blaster fire Darth Vader cloud city style
then Rey gives a punch of chewy moment as
she flies what looks like through this for
steer so like you said the TV spot in general
just focusing on Rey bad ass re-although we
do see a couple of the other planets the interesting
thing about the movie is is that a lot of
the locations a lot of the costumes will invoke
imagery from the original trilogy but they'll
be new plan of Jakku looks like tattooing
Tocco Donna looks like Endor you get the idea's
everybody get height and let me know like
who do you think that Rey's parents are regardless
of who the other characters might be related
to I feel like there's a pretty obvious choice
based on the marketing of the film what I
meant to do for the giveaway is it'll just
stay open until I post my next Star Wars video
and there is a war craft giveaway that's going
on right now giving away an epic war craft
mount from the the trailer that I post the
other day that's gonna go down the next war
craft video that I post was to be sometime
later this week so couple cool giveaways happening
it if you guys are confused about like when
I announced giveaway winners usually announce
the winner in the next video based on what
whatever thing the giveaways happening in
just acacias haven't seen it though I posted
a whole bunch of Star Wars footage you can
click here just to start the loop that just
like a couple trailers a couple TV spots and
some speculation and you can click here for
the flash and Supergirl trailers from this
week for episodes that are coming up thank
you so much for watching, everybody high five
and I'll see you tonight!